when living conditions worsen and the
economy fails people try to find reasons
for their troubles this is when
political extremists can become popular
as they blame certain groups of people
and promise that by getting rid of them
society's problems will go
away this can lead to the deliberate
elimination of those who are different
because of their race religion sexuality
or disability a phenomenon known as
genocide
the 10 stages of genocide are a
framework for understanding how crimes
against humanity happen so we can spot
early warning signs and potentially
prevent
them stage one is classification
extremists divide people into separate
groups based on their different
characteristics this often happens to
create an US versus them mentality or to
find someone to blame for social
problems the second stage is
symbolization this involves assigning
symbols or names to members of the other
group the goal here is to split the
society and make it clear Who belongs to
who third is discrimination the dominant
group uses its power to deny others
certain rights or privileges particular
new laws May limit the freedom of the
marginalized ones in instances of
bullying increase and the societal
divide
widens fourth is
dehumanization the targeted group is
portrayed as less than human often
compared to animals or diseases
stripping away the human qualities of a
person makes it easier to justify
violence against
them fifth is
organization this stage can involve
violent mobs that are tolerated by the
ruling class or or even the creation of
state sponsored militias in some
instances perpetrators now carefully
start to plan the next steps of the
genocide sixth is
polarization extremists now demonize the
targeted group and try to fully divide
Society by demanding that everyone must
take a side moderators who want to
reduce the tensions are often identified
as enemies and
silenced
seventh is preparation the criminals now
plan for mass murder they may identify
victims by name or number find where
they live and acquire weapons or build
facilities to Aid their
efforts eth is persecution violence
escalates the targeted group is
systematically subjected to harassment
displacement or other forms of abuse
often all of that happens under the
disguise of sec security
measures ninth is extermination the mass
killing Begins the culprits view their
victims as less than human believing
they are cleansing the world of an
undesirable element and in doing so
justify the use of disproportionate
violence 10th is denial those
responsible for the cruelty deny their
crimes destroy evidence blame the
victims and attempt to re write history
justifying their actions as necessary
for the greater
good this is why in the aftermath of
genocide the criminals must be made
accountable and the trauma must be
addressed then the survivors May heal
and Society can attempt to
reunite note that the 10 stages may not
occur linearly they can happen
simultaneously Dr Gregory Stant who
observed the phenomenon suggested
preventative measures to battle each
stage even though he believed that
ultimately only an international
intervention can stop such a
disaster in Germany Cambodia ruanda and
other places help from outside often
arrive too late for too many which is
why Stanton also founded genocide watch
a nonprofit to help prevent the next
tragedy from
unfolding
what do you think is knowledge enough to
prevent genocidal events and if not what
other measures can we take to avoid the
next human catastrophe share your
thoughts in the comments
[Music]
below if you found this helpful check
out our other videos and subscribe if
you want to support our work join us on
patreon.com sprouts for more information
and additional content visit Sprouts
schools.com